welcome back everyone this screencast is
an overview of the homework and bake off
associated with our unit on grounded
language understanding more than any of
the other assignments what we're asking
you to do here is essentially develop a
fully integrated system that addresses
our task
so the distinction between homework
questions and original system questions
is kind of getting blurred here in the
interest of having you devote all your
energy to developing a cool original
system for this problem
so because of that i'm going to use some
slides to give you an overview of the
entire problem and how we're thinking
about evaluation and how the questions
feed into these overall goals
so recall that our core task is the
stanford colors in context task and
we're going to take the speaker's
perspective primarily and what that
means is that the inputs to our model
are sequences of three color patches one
of them designated as the target and the
task is to generate
a description of the target in that
particular context
the core model that we'll be using which
is in torch color describer is an
encoder decoder architecture and the way
it works is on the encoder side you have
a sequence of three colors and we always
put the target color in the third
position
so those are the inputs and then the
decoding step is essentially to describe
the target in that context so that's the
natural language generation part and
we've covered this core architecture in
previous screencasts and i'll return to
some of the modifications that you see
here in the context of question four
there's a separate notebook called
caller's overview that you should start
with it gives you a sense for what the
data set is like and also what our
modeling code is like here you can see
that i've loaded in the corpus itself
it's got about 47 000 examples in it and
each one of those examples has a number
of different attributes that you should
be aware of so here's a typical example
the first one in the corpus
fundamentally you have these three color
patches and you can see this display is
marking out the target as well as an
utterance
each one of these colors is encoded as a
triple of hsv values that is a sequence
of three floats
and you can see here that you can also
access the utterance
there are three conditions in the
underlying corpus that vary in their
difficulty in the far condition all
three of the colors are quite different
from each other so the task of
identifying the target is typically
pretty easy here the person just had to
say purple
in the split condition two of the colors
are highly confusable so you can see
here that we have two green colors and
that pushed the speaker to choose a kind
of more specified form of green in
saying line
and the hardest condition is the close
condition and that's where all three of
the colors are highly similar to each
other this tends to lead to the longest
descriptions you can see here that the
speaker even took two turns as indicated
by this boundary marker to try to give
their full description medium pink the
medium dark one because these colors are
so confusable
so you should be aware of this
difference in the conditions and it
might affect how you do different kinds
of modeling based on what the color
sequence is like
now evaluation for natural image
generation systems is always challenging
and there are some automatic metrics
that we can use as guideposts in fact
we're going to use blue in various
places
but our primary evaluation metric will
be this task oriented one which brings
in a kind of listener perspective
so at a mechanical level here's how
we'll make predictions for a given
context c consisting of three colors
capital c here is all the permutations
of those three colors
suppose that you have trained a speaker
model ps here it's a probabilistic agent
we're going to think about how it makes
predictions for all of those different
permutations and take as its prediction
at the level of a full sequence
the sequence that it assigns the highest
probability to given the message that
your system produced
and then we say that a speaker is
accurate
in its prediction about some context c
just in case the
best sequence that it predicts the
highest probability one has the target
in the final position as designated by
our model structure
so in a little bit more detail here's
how this works with an example suppose
that our context looks like this it has
these three color patches and the target
is always in third position and our
message was blue
here on the right we have all the
permutations of these three colors and
we're going to say that your system was
correct if its highest probability
context given that message was one of
these two that is one of the two that
has the target in final position and the
system is inaccurate to the extent that
it signs higher probability to one of
these other sequences essentially we're
saying that it's assigning higher
probability to some other target but we
do operate at the level of these full
sequences
all right now let's move into the
questions here we first start with the
tokenizer you're unconstrained in how
you design your tokenizer you should
just make sure that you have a start
symbol and an n symbol the start symbol
is important conditioning context for
the model and the end symbol is a
crucial signal that your model will
actually actually stop producing tokens
so don't forget those pieces but in
terms of what else you do in there it's
unconstrained and i think you can see
from the monroe it all work that making
smart choices about tokenization might
be really meaningful
question two asks you to think about how
you're representing colors by default
they're just gonna be those three float
values but that's probably not optimal
uh in the monroe all paper we explore a
fourier transform as a way of embedding
colors and i've given you a little
recipe for that in the context of the
notebook in case you want to explore
that it is highly effective but this is
optional and there might be other
representation schemes that are even
better and worth exploring
question 3 asks you to think about rich
initialization or pre-training for your
model we've worked a lot with pre-chain
glove embeddings and this is a chance
for you to bring those into your model
and see how well they do you should be
aware that this step is going to
interact in non-trivial ways with
choices you make for your tokenizer
and question four is the most involved
that involves some real pie torch
wrangling conceptually what we're asking
you to do is borrow a trick from the
monroe at all paper what we found in
that work is that it helped to remind
the model during decoding of which of
the three colors was its target the way
we did that essentially was by taking
the color embedding for the target and
appending it to the embedding of each
one of the tokens that it was producing
as a kind of reminder
in terms of how that works at the level
of code there is a decoder class and you
should modify it so that the input
vector to the model at each time step is
not just the token embedding but the
concatenation of that embedding with the
representation of the target color
then you need to modify the encoder
decoder class to extract the target
colors and feed them to that decoder
class
and then finally here this is the
interface that you use modify that
interface so that it uses your decoder
encoder and that's a pretty mechanical
step
when you're developing on this problem
use toy data sets because you don't want
to wait around as you process the entire
colors corpus only to find out that you
have a low level bug and i also
encourage you to lean on the tests that
we have included in the notebook as a
way of ensuring that you have exactly
the right data structures i'm assuming
all those pieces fall into place i think
you'll find that the resulting models
are substantially better for our task
that brings us to the original system
and here's just some expectations about
how we think you might work on this
problem
you could iteratively improve your
answers to the assignment questions as
part of the original system modify the
tokenizer think about your glove
embeddings think about how you're
representing colors and kind of how all
those pieces are interacting
you might want to extend the modified
encoder decoder classes to do new and
interesting things and i provided
guidance on how to do that at a
mechanical level in the colors overview
notebook
any data that you can find is fine to
bring in for development and for
training your original system
the bake off involves a new test set
that's never been released anywhere
before it's just used in this context
it's got the same kinds of color context
as in the released corpus
but it was one-off games rather than
iterated games and i do think that makes
this test set a little bit easier than
the training set
and all the items have been listener
validated so i think all the
descriptions are in principle good
descriptions at a human level and so it
should be a good basis for evaluation
you